hello everybody very good morning to you
it is seven o'clock this thursday
morning you're very welcome uh to join
us here on the breakfast program on sky
news more nuclear power stations
more offshore wind power and more oil
and gas from the north sea that appears
to be the government's strategy for
keeping the lights on and reducing the
uk's dependence on energy from russia
but it's been criticized by
environmentalists who accuse ministers
of abandoning their climate targets and
it won't do much to cut soaring
household bills either i'm going to be
chatting to the energy secretary quasi
quatting and here's a quiz question you
might help us answer how can someone be
non-domiciled in the uk for tax purposes
but still live in dining street talking
about that thursday 7th of april
going nuclear the prime minister
promises eight new power plants but no
targets are set for onshore wind
the chancellor's wife defends her
non-dom status which means she doesn't
pay tax here on money she earns millions
she earns abroad
also this morning the savior of mario
paul how a fearless mechanic has rescued
180 people from the besieged city
and here in brussels nato foreign
ministers are meeting to discuss what
more they will do to help ukraine as the
country braces for a major attack from
russia in the eastern donbas region
a security guard at the british embassy
in berlin accused of spying for russia
will appear at westminster magistrates
court this morning
joined by an raf pilot who was told he
may never fly again after being
diagnosed with a rare incurable blood
cancer he went on to command the red
arrows
that gracie up there is where
we head through
tomorrow to get to camp 2
and they made it we'll speak to the
former uh professional rugby player
who's overcome a broken neck and
paralyzed limbs to climb mountains in
nipple
[Music]
morning everybody the prime minister's
promised cheaper energy bills as the
government announces a major new
investment in nuclear power the
government says its energy strategy will
take back control of soaring energy
costs but labor insist it won't do
anything to bring down bills
here's more detail of the new energy
strategy the government has set a target
of raising offshore wind generation by
five times by 2030 but there's no target
for onshore wind they're also pushing to
increase solar power generation but the
government is really putting its hopes
into nuclear power promising up to eight
new nuclear power stations by 2030 just
around the corner there are also plans
to double the amount of energy produced
by hydrogen
and there'll be a new licensing round
for oil and gas projects in the north
sea which has drawn criticism from green
groups
waiting to speak to the minister about
that we'll bring you the energy
secretary's comments in just a few
moments but first
another political story that's making
the headlines this morning ali is here
how much tax does the chancellor's wife
pay on our overseas earnings here in the
uk
well this is a question that everyone is
asking this morning non-dom status that
means that she doesn't pay tax on money
and outside the uk here in the uk
usually people that have non-dom status
don't actually live in the country but
it's important to point out legally no
suggestion of wrongdoing at all but
obviously i think it's just bad optics
isn't it it plays into the criticism
that we've seen of the chancellor not
being in touch the chancellor that this
week raised national insurance for so
many people the impact of the cost of
living crisis it plays in to um that
that really difficult week that we've
had for him the criticism that he's
given a hundred thousand pounds to a top
private school winchester college uh
criticism about the spring statement not
going far enough we've seen his um his
his popularity in the polls with
conservative members and with the public
really plummeting and now this news
about his wife worth saying you know she
is rich woman in her own right her
father is a billionaire he owns the
company infosys she has shares in that
company um and uh
that com that company we're saying was
criticized last week because of it's it
wasn't quick enough to cut its ties with
russia she has said uh in a statement
that she's a citizen of india the
country of her birth and her parents
home india doesn't allow its citizens to
hold the citizenship of another country
simultaneously and according to british
law miss murti is treated as a
non-domiciled for tax purposes she will
always and will continue to pay uk taxes
on all her uk income but that isn't
enough for a lot of people labour
accusing the government of one rule for
them one role for everyone else yeah and
we saw the chancellor he goes out of his
way to try to be a man of the people we
saw him put in uh fuel in a kia car
didn't we when he was talking about
cutting fuel duty we've seen him serving
burgers previously in a restaurant with
his name tag on and yet um the team
telling me this morning that according
to forbes he's worth 3.1 billion pounds
none of this
even if it is not it's not illegal we
know it's not illegal what they're up to
but it's not going to sit well with the
british public who are having to choose
between heating and eating yeah you're
right it's been
this was a chancellor who could do no
wrong when he first came in you'll
remember he sort of rose to stardom when
sanja javid stepped down um but it has
been a really difficult week he is a
wealthy man in his own right he used to
work at goldman sachs as i say his wife
is a daughter of a billionaire but
things like filling up someone else's
car the spring statement that hasn't
gone down well none of that paints a
good picture and labour are really
trying to seize on this you're almost
seeing them shifting their attack onto
the chancellor because they knew that he
was someone if he came into power and he
was tipped to be the person that might
replace boris johnson when his
leadership was really shaky over party
gate um
they are really focusing their attacks
now on rashi sunak and his him being
someone that isn't in touch one rule for
them one rule for everyone else to say
okay uh we'll chat to you again later
and of course ali's take at nine o'clock
looking forward to that thanks very much
indeed for now thanks a lot some
technical issues uh with the minister
will bring uh his comments to you just
as soon as we possibly can but first
let's tell you what's happening uh with
ukraine it can absolutely win the war
against russia according to the pentagon
as officials say russia's retreat from
the capital kiev is largely complete but
a warning from ukraine that russian
forces are now preparing for a huge
attack in the east of the country and as
accusations of russian war crimes mount
the un general assembly could vote to
remove russia from the human rights
council when it meets later on so let's
find out more should we on uh the
foreign ministers actually are meeting
in brussels for a second day of talks
about how best to support ukraine sally
is there
for us um hi sally they started chatting
yesterday we're going to be speaking to
the spanish foreign minister later on uh
how far did they get yesterday
well some progress was made uh in talks
they had a working dinner last night
where the foreign secretary liz trusts
urged nato partners to toughen uh their
stance against russia but if you just
think a week ago okay all eyes were on
istanbul those peace talks that were
taking place and the high hopes that
were pinned on a potential breakthrough
well now a week on all eyes are on this
nato summit uh here in brussels the
second day of talks about to uh begin
and of course what's unfolded in ukraine
uh in the space of those uh two talks is
quite extraordinary and many uh would
find it hard would have found it hard to
believe some of the um terrible
atrocities that have emerged in the last
week and certainly there is pressure on
nato
to respond today and offer more military
help to ukraine uh now the foreign
minister for ukraine has also arrived a
few moments ago with the nato secretary
general jens stoltenberg and he urged
nato to do more he said put aside your
hesitations your reluctance and give
ukraine everything it needs weird as it
sounds weapons serve the purpose of
peace and here was his very simple
message to nato
my agenda is very simple it has only
three items on it
its weapons
weapons and weapons
we are confident that the best way
to help ukraine now is to provide it
with all necessary to contain
putin
and to defeat russian army in ukraine in
the territory of ukraine
dimitro krilleb also said
let's hope we don't have to see another
butcher in order to get tougher
sanctions and we the support we need of
course butcher was that town just
outside kiev where those uh horrific
images emerged uh just a couple of days
ago which shocked the world
and there is now pressure on nato to
respond to that but of course they have
the delicate balancing act of not
wanting to be seen by vladimir putin to
becoming directly
involved in this war but certainly early
signs that the czech republic may be
sanded maybe sending tanks uh into
ukraine the first nato country to do so
it also has emerged in the last 24 hours
that america is training ukrainian
troops to use drones over
at ukraine and also reports in the times
today from a defense
source
that the uk government government may
also be providing armored vehicles such
as
the mastiff or jackal uh to help ukraine
uh as well but there does seem to be a
window of opportunity according to
british intelligence now as russian
troops reorganize uh and re-arm
themselves uh to offer more support to
ukraine because of course there is the
logistical challenge of getting all
those extra weapons and hardware into
the country and into the positions that
it's needed uh but suggestions that it
could take a week if not more for
russian troops to reorganize so the
pressure is on now for nato to give
ukraine what it needs
okay sally for now thank you and as i
said we're going to be speaking to the
spanish foreign affairs minister uh a
little bit later on in the programme and
indeed um i am iceland's first lady as
well tax show today meantime
the ukrainian city of mario paul has
been absolutely devastated by russian
bombardment since the early days of the
war with those trapped having little to
no access to food and water we're going
to be talking about that uh in more
detail in just a few moments time uh but
i'm pleased to say we sorted out the um
technical difficulties with the minister
quasi quatting and he's joining us now
hello to you mr martin sorry about that
those gremlins early in the morning we
appreciate you bearing with us uh let's
talk about uh energy strategy first of
all should we uh obviously that's your
brief uh now cop is out of the way we
talked a lot during that time didn't we
and there's a war
in ukraine um is net zero less of a
priority for the government
but not at all i think that the net zero
legislation it is after all uh in in law
uh is still the law of the land we're
focused on that but of course given
what's happening around the world given
the pressure on energy prices we're also
doing lots of other things to make sure
that we get independence energy
independence back
into the uk
we want to have a security of supply we
want to live in a world where we're not
dependent on what russian policy is but
we have more control
over energy sources here in britain and
that's what the strategy is all about
yeah what people care more most about at
the moment though of course is the
impact that it's going to have on their
energy bills when will they see the
difference
you're absolutely right i mean in terms
of people's energy bills our people's
energy bills this year
we've
announced the measure of uh a number of
measures the 9.1 billion pound uh
package the 150 pounds
of uh council tax for people in bands a
to d
uh 200 pounds to to pay those bills
and of course you're right to say that
the strategy
is more of a a medium-term three four
five year uh uh answer but that doesn't
mean we can't address this i think it's
really important uh that we get an
energy price uh strategy and energy
policy that means that we can have more
security and independence uh in the
years ahead
how comfortable would you be living next
door to a wind farm
i've said that i don't personally have
uh issues with wind farms but of course
i've also very clearly said
that uh wind farm onshore wind farm
developments have to be made with local
consent that doesn't work without that
and that's what we're
that's what we're committed to in the
strategy
okay
um let's move on to the front page of
the daily mirror today in the news this
morning do you um let's have a quick
look at that do you agree
uh with the chancellor uh rishi sunak
who says that because his wife isn't an
elected politician journalist shouldn't
be asked questions about her
look i agree with him that it's
completely unfair to be bringing someone
who is
not a politician
and and and essentially attacking them
uh in the way that that's happening
um i totally agree with him on that
how does it look to the british public
that while they're being asked to pay
more tax from yesterday
the wife of the man who is asking us to
do that is earning millions from
overseas investments and not paying a
penny
so she's uh i
looked at her statement uh yesterday
she made it very clear
that as an indian national she can't
have dual
citizenship
and she's got a non-dom status here in
the uk
now after 15 years staying she will be
domiciled but for the moment
she pays tax on
uk income as i understand and
on foreign income she pays the tax
outside the uk that's what non-domiciled
status uh means but i haven't come here
to
comment on on on her tax affairs
we're talking about the british public
and the optics um if i may you are here
to represent the government today not
just on your own brief that's your job
this morning on behalf of her majesty's
government and i'm asking you about the
optics of the british public who are
being asked to pay more money and making
the choice between heating and eating
half a million kids in absolute poverty
and the woman who is married to the
bloke that is enforcing all of that on
us is not paying a penny in tax for
overseas earnings i'm asking you about
the optics of that for my viewers this
morning
so all i've said is yeah people can
reach obviously
their own conclusions and that's up to
the viewers but all i've said is that
he's made full declaration of uh what's
happened uh she it's a non-domiciled
status that is utterly legal everything
is completely in order he's always been
very transparent
uh about about these issues
she set up a business with others called
dig me fitness it went under only went
under
after it had taken quite a lot of money
as part of the furlough scheme debts of
415 000 pounds uh that has been left uh
to the a british taxpayer uh to pick up
and again i would put it to you that
this is somebody who is richer than the
queen who is living in the very heart of
westminster representing your government
are you completely comfortable with that
i'm totally comfortable with people
having businesses
people operating what they do as private
citizens
i'm completely comfortable
about that and i think everything has
been uh
open and declared
and i'm happy with that i don't know the
details um obviously i'm not
an expert on on
those financial financial arrangements
but i think absolutely uh that people
have a right to
pursue their own business interests
635 000 pounds infolo payments for a
company that collapsed
look i don't know about
i don't know about the details of the
businesses that were uh that you're
referring to
um but i know that everything uh has
been uh fully declared um i know that
uh the chancellor has put this all in
his declaration of interests and i also
am aware that the non-domiciled status
is something that's been in british law
for 230 years
can you accept at all that it might um
irk the british public
the people will draw their own
conclusions and that's what we that's
the great thing about this country we
have an open debate people will have
lots of different views i've just come
here to say
very clearly
that i think her tax affairs are a
matter for her
and i don't know the details of the
businesses that you've referred to no i
understand that i understand that but i
i can't understand why you don't
appreciate that somebody can't feed
their kids put food in their bellies and
put the lights on in the house as well
and yet somebody else who's married to
somebody who's making us make those
decisions is making millions in overseas
earnings and not having to pay a penny
in tax
we've rehearsed this i said there's a
non-domiciled status that you uh clearly
and lots of people are aware of
um and everything's been declared that's
that's that's what i've said okay let me
ask you about okay let me ask you this
instead then do you agree with the prime
minister that biological males uh should
not be competing in uh female sporting
events
yes i do i think he was very clear it
was very refreshing
to see a
the leading politician in our country be
very clear about that i happen to agree
with him on this
okay um
the charity stonewall i'm sure you're
aware of them are saying that a blanket
ban would be fundamentally
unfair why are they wrong
i think that we've seen uh in america
and other places
people who are biological males you know
smash uh records uh and win lots and
lots of uh uh races and i think that
that's
uh i think that's unfair i think what
the prime minister said chimed with
millions of people's views up and down
the country
that it's unfair to have biological
males uh competing uh with biological uh
females uh in in
things like swimming contests and
cycling
um you're completely comfortable with
what's happening at number 11 down in
the street what about number 10 are you
comfortable that the prime minister in
the words of the leader of the
opposition presided over widespread
criminality while in office
so again you know we've been here uh
many times i think it's important that
the police uh go through the full a
metropolitan police go through the full
investigation
they're doing that
uh as i understand a number of people
have been issued with fines
and
that's up to those uh individuals
uh concerned we've had sue gray as well
looking at what's happened and i'm just
very interested in looking into the
conclusion
of those reports yeah the interim report
says that 20 times the law was broken in
downing street that some would say
that's widespread criminality i'm asking
you to comment on what might happen i'm
asking you about what the police have
already told us and are you completely
comfortable with the prime minister
who's presided over the law being broken
20 times already in office
what i am comfortable with is with the
prime minister who's shown incredible
leadership
uh in this russia ukraine crisis that's
not what i'm asking you about minister
pointed out
no
you're asking me about whether i'm
comfortable with the prime minister and
i'm 100 no i'm not i didn't ask you that
i asked you whether you were comfortable
with him presiding over law breaking is
what i'm asking you specifically
uh so on that specific point i'm saying
that let's see the full extent of the
inquiry but the underlying your question
was somehow some suspicion that the
prime minister no that was really that's
specifically what i was asking about no
there was no sidebar to it at all okay
let me put let me put this this is
the justice secretary the justice
secretary says laws were broken at
downing straight do you agree with him
or do you think he's misspoken
look all i was saying is that i think we
should look at the full extent of the
report i want to wait and see the full
uh gray report i want to wait and see
the full uh outcome
of the metropolitan investigations we're
in an interim stage as you said okay and
i think we should i will i will make my
conclusions once uh this process is
completed okay so the jury's still out
for you
thank you
thank you take a look at what i think i
just said let's wait let's wait and see
where this thing ends up thank you bye
thank you bye-bye thank you thank you
let's take a look at what some of the
front pages are saying this morning
should we let's start with the ft uh
leading on the latest russian sanctions
as western allies target yet more banks
the times reports that the uk is set to
send armored vehicles to aid ukraine in
the fight against russia the metro
quotes the prime minister saying he has
absolutely no problem with putting
national insurance tax up despite the
rise in energy bills
the eye's front page focuses on the
chancellor wishy sunak's wife stating
that she avoided tax through her non-dom
status
and the daily mirror also focus on the
chancellor's wife we were just talking
about that weren't we in detail with the
minister very kindly gave us his time to
talk about it and the guardian reports
that the prime minister's push for an
increase in the use of nuclear power has
divided members of his party and angered
environmental groups
still to come on the programme for you
at 7 30 as the government unveils its
new energy strategy speaking to a
personal finance expert about what the
plans will mean for us for our fuel
bills
then just after eight the shadow climate
and net zero secretary ed miliband will
join me in the studio as labour calls on
the prime minister step up and lead
on renewable energy
and at around 20 past eight we'll speak
to a gambling addict turned campaigner
and his entrepreneur son about the work
they're doing to educate gps about the
early signs of a hidden gambling
addiction
a security guard at the british embassy
in berlin suspected of spying for russia
will appear in court here in the uk
later on today is outside westminster
magistrates court for us this morning
good morning to you tell us more about
this story if you would
well david smith as you've said he was a
security guard at the british embassy in
berlin and the 57 year old is being
accused of spying for the russian state
the crown prosecution service and
metropolitan police work together to
build up a prosecution case against him
and as a result he has been charged with
nine offenses contrary to the official
secrets act when we look at the
breakdown of this
seven of the offences he's been accused
of relate to collecting information with
intent to send it to russian authorities
there's one event of attempting
communication and one other offence of
providing information to a person he
believed was a member of russian
authorities now the alleged offences
took place between october 2020 and
august last year and it was august last
year the 10th of august when he was
arrested by german police and he had
been held in custody since then the
crown prosecution service and the
metropolitan police have been working
together with their german counterparts
to extradite him of course that happened
yesterday and today he is expected to
appear here at westminster magistrates
court okay thank you very much indeed
thanks a lot um i think the technical
term for the weather overnight was it
was flipping bucketing down
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
turning colder with blustery showers
becoming increasingly wintry mostly cold
and windy now with gales through central
park showers in the north more prolonged
snow for the grampians
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news our
top stories for you this morning the
government is set to reveal its energy
strategy for the uk with eight new
nuclear power stations set to be built
the chancellor's wife says she has
always paid tax on uk income as labour
demands to know if rishi sunak has
benefited from her tax status
and the pentagon has said ukraine can
absolutely win the war against russia as
officials say russia's retreat from the
capital kiev is largely complete
[Music]
the last half an hour the business
secretary has told me that the
government is still focused on its net
zero target as it prepares to release
its new energy strategy quasi quarten
also told me he wants the uk to have
full control of its own energy sources
but not at all i think that the net zero
legislation it is after all uh in in law
uh is still the law of the land we're
focused on that but of course given
what's happening around the world given
the pressure on energy prices
we're also doing lots of other things to
make sure
that we get independence energy
independence back
into the uk
we want to have a security of supply we
want to live in a world where we're not
dependent on what russian policy is but
we have more control
over energy sources here in in britain
and that's what the strategy is all
about
that's what he's saying ali about energy
um he wasn't quite as comfortable to
answer my questions about mrs sunak he
really wasn't was was he he did not
enjoy that at all i didn't think um you
i think rightly were pushing him on the
criticism that we've seen rishi sunak's
wife's non-dom status meaning that she
doesn't pay tax on income earned outside
the uk she's obviously a very wealthy
woman daughter of a billionaire has a
big stake in her father's company um
worth pointing out that legally no no
suggestion of wrongdoing at all but
clearly bad optics but he said to you uh
i haven't come here to comment on her
tax affairs he i mean he really didn't
want to answer it he sort of repeated
again and again what we heard in her
statement uh effectively uh that uh she
is a citizen of india that she um that
that she doesn't need to that it was
already declared in all the proper ways
should we listen yes let's have a listen
uh she pays tax on
uk income as i understand and
on foreign income she pays the tax uh uh
outside the uk that's what non-domiciled
status uh means but i haven't come here
to
comment on on on her tax affairs
well talking about the british public
and the optics
if i may you are here to represent the
government today not just on your own
brief that's your job this morning on
behalf of her majesty's government
and i'm asking you about the optics of
the british public who are being asked
to pay more money and making the choice
between heating and eating half a
million kids in absolute poverty and the
woman who is married to the bloke that
is enforcing all of that on us is not
paying a penny in tax for overseas
earnings i'm asking you about the optics
of that for my viewers this morning
so all i've said is you know people can
reach obviously their own conclusions
and that's up to the viewers but all
i've said is that uh he's made full
declaration of uh what's happened
oh that was squeaky bump time wasn't it
absolutely and partygate as well he just
sort of stared you out on one of those
quests
um easier for him because he's not an
excuse minister so isn't it you know
because they they have to come out and
defend things that they don't i suppose
in private necessarily agree with yeah
exactly and you know all of these are
questions for the chancellor it's been a
pretty tough week for him
criticism of the spring statement not
going far enough criticism of the
hundred thousand pounds that he gave to
his old school winchester college he's
seen his poll ratings plummet um so
these were questions obviously you were
going to ask government minister were
saying you know i think it's fair to say
that there has been friction between the
treasury and the business department on
this energy strategy and not a huge
amount of new money has come with this
so he was facing those tough questions
but um i think was pretty keen not to
answer any of them directly yeah tough
week as you say for the chancellor
perhaps tougher for those who can't
afford to heat their homes anymore
some might say we'll see you at the top
of the next hour thank you thanks ellie
thank you uh well we're hearing from
quasi quatting and ali was pointing out
there that uh energy bills could start
to fall but only in two to three years
time so what happens between now and
then financial expert and founder of
money magpie jasmine bertholds is with
us now hi jasmine um
challenging time for so
many uh of my viewers this morning where
do they start to try to make ends meet
as you say it's very difficult and and
you know people like me really are
coming to the end of the
tips that we can give and and you get to
a point where frankly you're sounding
patronizing when you know you're
mentioning all the the small things that
we could do there are many people and i
have neighbors who are in this situation
who really have cut back as far as they
can go really um and they are just
looking at how they can pay these bills
and also pay the rising cost of food
it's it's very tough for people
uh it is the next energy price cap rise
comes in i think in october
what can people expect from that
well
i'm sorry to say another rise um you
know
this really does seem to be um through
the trajectory at the moment certainly
for this year um one potential uh
glimmer of hope is that the price of oil
could be coming down towards the end of
the of the year so that would mean that
petrol
should be cheaper and also some gas you
would expect because of some gas it
comes through the production of oil um
so you know that is some sort of glimmer
of hope but in the short term i would
say that we are looking at very high
energy bills at home um and you know
we're coming into the summer it's spring
summer that's going to make it easier
and i i do suggest that people um save
as much as they can um putting money
aside for the winter um because that as
you say you know we're getting the um
increase in october um
and it's going to be very tough over the
winter i think do you think that the
chancellor may do anything in the short
term to try to help people more than
what he's already said
well i was very disappointed by the
spring statement i really thought that
he would pull something out of the hat
to do with energy prices but afterwards
it did occur to me that maybe he's
keeping his powder dry for the budget um
that he knows that prices are going to
be even higher then so it's possible
that he will come up with something
maybe um a short term rise to universal
credit something for
pensioners something for those who are
already on benefits honestly i don't
know i'm sadly i'm not privy to his his
discussions but i i suspect i hope in
all honesty that there is something that
they are considering to bring out in in
the budget to help those who are the
most vulnerable
okay uh let's wait and see thanks so
much indeed jasmine thank you
hello again welcome back to the
breakfast show here on sky the ukrainian
city of mariopol has been devastated by
russian bombardment since the early days
of the war with those trapped having
little to no access to food or water but
despite the tragedy one man's bravery
has led him to be called the hero of
mario paul he's helped 180 people flee
in his soviet era saloon car here's
ashna
in a city paralyzed by this war
only the flimsy remnants of homes remain
few have managed to escape mariupol as
it was pounded into submission
but alexei has been risking his life
going back in for the last three weeks
each time rescuing the most vulnerable
and often coming under attack himself
why yes that's right
the former submarine engineer says he's
fulfilling a duty saving lives in his
hometown
each time alexei returns he finds yet
more desperation
is
alexei has so far single-handedly
rescued 180 people including children
all in his beloved saloon
[Applause]
[Music]
it's ordinary civilians like alexei that
are some people's only hope of rescue a
tale of heroism from the darkest of
places
nato meetings are taking place in
brussels this week and foreign ministers
will address president putin's brutal
invasion of ukraine allies are stepping
up their support for ukraine's right to
defend itself with things like anti-tank
weapons air defense systems and
increased humanitarian assistance and
financial aid well mark voyager former
special adviser for russian and eurasian
affairs is with us now hello thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
um
a lot of talk going on in brussels at
the moment meantime we're hearing from
the ukrainian president saying that's
not what i need what i need is your help
on the ground it's a very difficult
situation isn't it and it continues
uh it does definitely and especially
when the world has seen the devastation
that the russian troops have left the
despicable images on the ground and the
cities uh surrounding kiev and this is
only the beginning this is really the
russian way of war
and uh all this uh graphic footage has
actually shown the world that ukraine
needs all the help and more and it needs
now
just about an hour ago
the ukraine foreign minister actually
spelled it out quite
quite eloquently and uh succinctly and
simply he said you know there's no
offensive weapons in this war and
everything you give us is defensive
because we fight on our own territory so
he's asking for much more than anti-tank
weapons he's asking for armor
airplanes
obviously
short c missiles
and high altitude air defense
so all these can be a
factor a multiplying factor in the in
the war
uh against russia so that uh
ukraine can create its own
uh you know its own uh no-fly zone if
you will and also prevent the the
russians from committing even more uh
such despicable atrocities and this is
really again the tip of the iceberg what
we have seen
there's no way nato
would would say no to such a plea in
such a such a critical moment
we know that the czech republic is in a
position where it's planning
to send
more
hardware military hardware to help in
ukraine russia has said that western
arms convoys to ukraine are a legitimate
target
does the czech republic particularly
realize the sort of challenges that they
might be facing going forward
everybody realizes it i'm sure the
czechs are well aware of that and so are
the other eastern european states some
are more reluctant to help
exactly because of this reason but but
look uh the russian propaganda has been
uh you know has been blaring really for
months that they're actually not
fighting only ukraine in ukraine they're
fighting american nato so so in their
own minds they're actually already
fighting the west and therefore
you know providing uh providing weapons
is not really uh you know an escalation
of this of this nature uh actually we
should push our eastern european uh nato
member states uh to actually provide
more because they are the ones that hope
that still have the soviet era or
russian uh
made equipment that is bulgaria slovakia
poland they were also talk initially
they were talks about
poland providing uh airplanes and others
and other assets and think about it uh
turkey has been providing a baractar
drones that actually
that have decimated the russian armor in
ukraine and turkey is hosting
meetings diplomatic high-level uh
summits with with russia and ukraine and
you know russia so far hasn't attacked
turkey so you know that that's i think
it's a flawed it's a flawed argument
that if you provide uh aid the russians
will automatically target
your country
we heard from the chairman of the
defense uh select committee of
parliament um a guy called tobias elwood
on the program earlier in the week and
he was saying that we should be sending
nato ships to the black sea to defend
odessa
would that mean that nato was taking
part in the war if they did that
well um the black sea is nothing is not
it is now being turned into a russian
lake just like the as of sea was and the
black sea actually is shared by
several nato nations that's romania
bulgaria turkey uh so i would say no i
mean ultimately we need to do that you
know i've been i've been talking also
for a couple of years that we should
have sent nato ships on visits to also
mario opal back in the back in the day
when when the russians attacked the
the um the ukrainian uh cutters in the
in the kurd straight so um you know if
there's an offline zone i mean if you
know we feel reluctant to impose it we
can do something about a no sail zone if
you will in the black sea because russia
has been targeting international
navigation you know think of the 1980s
when the u.s
fifth lethals was protecting the
attackers across the persian gulf
they're there there are precedents and
we can use
some of this these legal precedents to
actually uh impose some costs on the
russians at least protect international
navigation and and mine sweeping the
russians have been this you know uh
letting uh free-floating mines uh trying
to blend ukrainians and these these pose
also tremendous threat to the coastal
nations of black sea and the
international navigation all the ships
going there most of it is grain actually
headed to the middle east in africa
come summer there will be tremendous uh
food shortages in the in the global
south and this will be another uh
another one of russia's hybrid
tools in the world in in the war against
the international legal in order
effectively
okay um
who's winning this war at the moment
definitely ukraine ukraine is winning it
on the ground tactically operationally
um internationally strategically i would
say uh information wise the information
warfare is definitely
critical um
unfortunately you know putin is still in
power and he is winning the war at home
that is he is slowly but surely
recreating the soviet system you know a
totalitarian system that bans all
descent and has stifled all access to
free information so internationally
ukraine is winning
domestically russia is winning until
such time that we're able to penetrate
through this thick wall of lies and
propaganda and convince the russian
people that he's uh
he's bad even for russia he has to be
taken down he's no longer the legitimate
leader of the russian federation from
the point of view of the world
but do you agree that this war could go
on for years
uh if he stays in power it will go for
gone for years and this is this is what
his regime thrives on i mean he's
his his popularity source every time
there is a war
so he's using the salami tactics as we
call it and in the us you know he may he
may stop he may be stopped on during
this iteration and then regroup uh
regenerate his forces and then attack
again in the in the in the late summer
early fall next year i mean for as long
as he's alive he won't let ukraine exist
as an independence over a state and we
must help them uh you know defeat defeat
this
effectively monstrosity that's facing
not only them but
but the west
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
for taking the time to join us on the
program this morning thank you
and as you know foreign ministers are
still meeting uh for a second day
actually in brussels european foreign
ministers to try to come up with a plan
to further help the people of ukraine to
that end we're going to be speaking to
this spanish foreign minister
jose manuel alvarez that's coming up in
the next hour actually here on sky news
before that though let's show you what
the business secretary quasi quatern
said earlier on in the program when i
asked him about reports the chancellor's
wife it's in all the papers today the
chancellor's wife doesn't pay tax here
on the millions that she earns overseas
she pays tax on
uk income as i understand and
on foreign income she pays the tax
uh outside the uk that's what
non-domiciled status uh means but i
haven't come here to
comment on on on her tax affairs
we're talking about the british public
and the optics
if i may you are here to represent the
government today not just on your own
brief that's your job this morning on
behalf of her majesty's government and
i'm asking you about the optics of the
british public who are being asked to
pay more money and making the choice
between heating and eating half a
million kids in absolute poverty and the
woman who is married to the bloke that
is enforcing all of that on us is not
paying a penny in tax for overseas
earnings i'm asking you about the optics
of that for my viewers this morning
so all i've said is you know people can
reach obviously their own conclusions
and that's up to the viewers but all
i've said is that he's made full
declaration of what's happened
let us know what you think you can tweet
me directly if you would like to at k
burley cutting those um uh grabs as we
call them in the trade for twitter as we
speak so if you want to listen again
before you formulate your view you can
always reply underneath those tweets uh
ben uh and jack on that for you this
morning first have a look at the papers
this is the telegraph
well it says that robins are seen in
sunderland and probably lots of places
as well this male robin is feeding its
mate in the garden in an example of
what's called courtship feeding
which is nice and earlier in the week it
wouldn't work for me earlier in the week
one of you uh watching sent in this
photo you'd snap to three majestic
giraffes in namibia remember we were
showing it to you like a three-headed
giraffe
continue with the theme the sun has this
great image of three lions kicking back
in the south african sun see at the top
of the hour do you hope so
you